MARC VANDEMEULEBROECKE: My
name is Marc Vandemeulebroecke.
I work at Novartis.
And I just want to
say a few motivating
words on why we're
doing what we're doing
and what you can
expect to hear today.
We start from the inside
that graphics and visuals
are such an important
component of the work we
do as quantitative scientists.
They're so important for
ourselves to gain insights
into data, as well
as for communicating
results and conclusions
to our stakeholders.
And if you've been following
all those coronavirus charts out
there for the past
few weeks, like I did,
you will agree that graphics
are key to understanding
what's going on.
Unfortunately, however,
we are not always
good at creating
effective graphs.
How often do we
see or even create
ineffective visualizations?
And do we even know
which choices or features
make a graph effective for a
particular purpose or audience?
This is our first focus to
convey this understanding.
And this point is actually
part of a wider initiative
beyond today's webinar.
And you will find a
corresponding link
at the end of these slides.
Secondly, once we do know
what makes an effective graph,
how easily can we
actually implement it?
That is, create it quickly
and with minimal effort.
This is our second focus--
the development of
an R package that
has good graphical
principles sort of built in,
building upon many of the
great packages out there,
and minimizing the code
required for the user.
We quickly realized
that these themes
are of common interest across
Roche, Novartis, and probably
many other companies
and institutions.
So we have started to team
up and tackle them together.
And one of the
goals today is also
to call for additional
interested contributors, which
leads me to today's agenda.
After this introduction,
my colleague,
Mark Baille from
Novartis, will speak
about the principles of
effective visual communication
generally.
He will then hand over
to Charlotta Fruchtenicht
and Diego Saldana
from Roche, who
will focus more
specifically and a bit more
technically on the R package
which we've started to develop.
The goal of this package,
as I said earlier,
is to make it really easy to
implement those good principles
in practice, specifically in a
health care or drug development
context, which is where we work.
All this is work in progress.
And at the end of
the webinar we will
call for further contributors,
and we will hopefully also
have a few minutes for Q&amp;A.
So with that, Mark,
do you want to start?
MARK BAILLE: Thank you, Marc.
So effective data
visualization is a key scale
for all quantitative scientists,
including statisticians,
epidemiologists,
or data scientists,
whatever your current title is.
Traditionally, this
is a skill that
has not been a primary focus
in the training and development
of quantitative scientists.
In graduate degrees,
the focus is often
on analytical and
technical competencies.
The skill of visual
communication
is often self-taught, but
develops later on in the job.
So effective visualization
is extremely important.
It is a key skill that allows
us to convey complex concepts
and information to others.
If we get this right, it helps
support appropriate decisions
or actions.
If we get this
wrong, it can lead
to misinformation,
confusion, or even harm,
especially in clinical
and medical research.
The visualization on the
right is a good recent example
of this, covering the
current coronavirus pandemic.
The visualization was recently
published in The New York
Times.
It displays a concept
of social distancing
and why it is important.
It is important because it helps
break the transmission chain.
The graphic also illustrates the
concept of exponential growth.
This is something we've
heard a lot of recently.
Here we see an
infected individual who
goes on to infect two others.
They in turn infect
two others until we
begin to see many individuals
infected with the virus,
all stemming from
a single person.
By practicing
social distancing we
may break this chain,
therefore reducing
the number of subsequent
infections, which
could be substantial,
as displayed
in the bottom graphic.
We are not always good at it.
On the right is an example
from a clinical study report.
Waterfall plots
are commonly used
to report treatment response
in oncology clinical trials.
Aesthetically, this
plot doesn't look good,
from the choice of patterns
to the general look and feel.
For me, it feels like it was
produced by a typewriter rather
than modern software.
There is a lot not to
like about this plot.
But as I said earlier, if we
get visual communication wrong,
it can lead to the
wrong conclusions.
And then working in medical
and clinical research,
this can often result in harm.
So apart from the
aesthetic limitations,
the real failing of this graph
is not the look and feel,
but that the graph
expects the reader
to make calculations
mentally to compare treatment
effects across multiple doses.
Waterfall plots are often
used to support decision
making, especially in critical
indications found in oncology.
So asking the reader to make
those calculations mentally
isn't an effective
way to communicate.
So what do we mean by effective?
We don't necessarily
mean beautiful.
So we don't really mean
to focus on the beautiful.
So to illustrate
here is an example
of a visually appealing
graph from David McCandless.
He is a data artist and
journalist from the UK.
The visualization is called
Mountains out of Molehills:
a Timeline of Global
Media Scare Stories.
The visualization
attempts to investigate
the number of news
story reports,
and if there is a
sensible reporting.
And so this could cause
unnecessary panic.
It covers earlier
pandemics such as SARS,
bird flu, and swine flu, also
video games and killer wasps.
Visually it is appealing
and draws you in.
But I would argue
it's not effective,
as key information is
hidden away in the legend.
So if you look at
the legend, there
are numbers and brackets that
provide the deaths associated
with each story.
It's very difficult
to see, I can imagine.
This information is important
to determine if there really
is over-reporting.
But the information is not
factored into the main body
of the graph.
Also, the subtitle
uses languages
such as scare stories,
it has comparisons
to annual seasonal flu deaths,
and it also has comparisons
to topics such as video gaming.
All of these design
choices indirectly
influence the reader, which can
then influence decision making.
So beautiful and effective.
That's what we really want.
So here is an example of a
recent effective visualization
published by The Economist.
The visualization
captures a recent phrase
that we hear a lot of
now-- flatten the curve.
The graph summarizes
this concept really well.
So we have two
distributions of a time,
which represent the number of
infections in the population.
Each distribution
represents a strategy.
Strategy one for not taking
preventative measures
such as social distancing,
and strategy two, it does.
You can see that
strategy two reduces
the peak of the distribution
through social distancing.
This strategy
extends the epidemic
over a longer period
of time, but reduces
the peak number of infections.
The spatial visualization
is effective in introducing
this concept of
flattening the curve.
But can we be even
more effective?
So here is another
version of the same graph.
Aesthetically, it's not as
appealing as the previous one,
but by adding a dotted line
and a simple annotation--
Healthcare System Capacity--
this specialization now
highlights the why.
Why do we want to flatten
an infection curve
and spread an epidemic over
a longer period of time?
The purpose of
flattening the curve
is not to overwhelm
the health care system.
So the dotted line illustrates
that the first strategy
would result in more
infections than the health care
system could cope with.
This, sadly, can have
terrible consequences
that we are currently
witnessing now.
So both graphs are
very effective ways
to convey complex
concepts to the population
and getting messages out there.
And I just want to highlight
that both of these slides
were influenced by a
tweet from [INAUDIBLE]..
The link is there if you
want to follow up on it.
So effective visualization is
effective visual communication.
Effective graphs are visually
appealing, intuitive, legible,
and use correct graph
type and axis scales,
and use proximity and alignment
to facilitate comparisons,
and use labels and annotations
to add clarity to the message,
as I illustrated before.
And more importantly,
effective use of
visualizations enable clear
and impactful communication,
evaluate our influence
with our stakeholders,
and facilitate informed
decision making.
This is one of the
main motivations
behind the collaboration
that we are presenting today
and the initial design
of the visR package.
But how do we become
more effective?
Myself and colleagues
at Novartis
have been thinking about this
topic for a number of years.
We've tried a
number of approaches
to try and address this
question from reading
all the literature available,
defining best practices,
developing galleries
of codes, newsletters
to highlight the
importance of the topic,
to handing out
cheat sheets with--
and we've had various
levels of success.
But to make this concept stick
and to be easier to remember,
we recently defined what we call
the Three Laws for Effective
Visual Communication--
have a clear purpose,
show the data clearly,
and make the message obvious.
You can think of these
three laws as superheroes.
So have a clear purpose.
This is really about why
do we need this graph?
So you should really know the
purpose of creating the graph.
And this is really related
also to data analysis itself.
We should identify the
quantitative evidence
to support the purpose and
also identify the audience
and focus the design and
to support their needs.
Show the data clearly.
This is about avoiding
misrepresentation.
Choosing the appropriate graph
type to display the data,
maximizing data to ink ratio.
So this is really just a complex
way of saying, keep it simple.
Finally, make the
message obvious.
So using proximity and
alignment to aid in comparisons,
minimize mental arithmetic.
This is really going back
to the waterfall plot
where you really
don't want the reader
to be doing summations
in their head.
And using colors and annotations
to highlight important details.
So I'll now go through
each of these three laws
in more detail.
So Law 1-- Have a Clear Purpose.
This first law is really
advanced common sense.
It follows typical planning
questions such as why, what,
who, and where.
So why do I need a graph?
And what is its purpose?
Is it to explore data
or to deliver a message?
What evidence is available
to support this purpose?
This could be data sets, new
experiments, simulations,
for example.
OK.
Who is my intended audience?
Is it a mix of specialists
and non-specialists, or both?
You really need to think
about who this audience is
and support their needs.
And the where.
Where will I publish?
And what other
constraints they are?
So for the where, we may
identify certain formats
such as a Word document,
a PowerPoint presentation,
R Markdown notebook,
or a shiny app.
And really, the design and
the purpose and the principles
that we have really,
really is important for all
of these different formats.
But depending on the format,
some of these principles
may apply and the
design choices may vary.
Another aspect to this
law is to identify
what are the underlying
questions you
are trying to address.
So here I highlighted
an article by Roger Peng
that discusses his thoughts on
John Tukey, exploratory data
analysis, and design thinking.
He argues that better
analyses are related
to the quality of the question.
So more time spent on
defining better questions
is time well spent.
And this is related to
the famous Tukey quote--
"An approximate answer
to the right question
is worth a great deal
more than a precise answer
to the wrong question."
So the message here
is to spend more time
thinking about your question
prior to an analysis
and designing the visualization.
Another aspect to this
law is why are you
creating visualization?
So thinking about
this aspect can
help identify the
audience and their needs,
which in turn helps
with the design.
So for example, if you
want to dig deep into data,
get familiar with the data,
or find the story in my data,
the audience is normally you.
If you want to
communicate the results
or to tell the story
behind the data,
then the audience
is someone else.
So being clear on the
purpose is important here.
For example, if you're
designing the visualization
to be presented to a
group of stakeholders
where you have 3 minutes to get
your recommendations across,
do you really want the
audience to play Where's Wally?
Or in the case of
America, Where's Waldo?
And if you're really
interested, Wally
is in the middle of
the picture here.
Law 2, Show the Data Clearly.
The key part of this law is
not to lie or represent data.
Try to be open and
transparent of your analysis
and the reporting of it.
Here we have an example from
YouGov on the important topic
of pizza toppings.
The visualization displays
a pizza pie chart.
The visualization is confusing,
as the numbers add up to way
beyond 100%.
Another thing
that's confusing is
mushroom as the UK'S
most liked pizza topping.
So as a Scotsman, I really
find this hard to believe.
Another aspect of this
law is to be transparent.
Here I have displayed
a response from YouGov
to clarify the purpose
of their chart.
The intent was not to
display a pie chart,
but to present
percentages from a survey.
Here we see that being clear
and transparent builds trust,
and it helps with communication.
Another aspect to
this apology is
it highlights the need
to think carefully
about your design
and the graph type.
So choosing the correct graph
type aids in interpretation.
So thinking about the
purpose of the graph
can help identify
appropriate graph types.
Often we don't need to
reinvent the wheel here.
For example, if you want to
show a deviation, a correlation,
or a ranking, then there
are common graph types
that we can select from.
Another aspect to think
about in terms of graph type
is what information
do you want to convey?
So here's an example
of the same data
displayed six different ways.
The pie and donut
charts in panels A and B
make it difficult to see
the order of magnitude
of some of the segments.
They're only to compare
areas or angles.
These attributes are
not easy to compare.
The donut chart even
omits the angles
and bends the areas to make
it more challenging to make
these comparisons.
The mosaic plot in Panel
C only relies on areas.
Again, it's hard to
compare across categories.
And it's better to use
lengths with a common baseline
or possessions on a common
scale, such as a bar chart
or dot plot.
The bar chart in
Panel D, though,
introduces a fake dimension,
which is unnecessary
and makes it hard to
compare numerical values
from the height of the bars.
Panels E and F are simple
and show the data clearly.
They also order the
data by magnitude
to aid comparison even further.
So you're really not
making the reader work
or do the mental
arithmetic in their heads.
The dot plot in Panel
F uses minimal ink
and draws eye to the
position of the dots.
So it's probably the
most effective way
of displaying the data.
Choose the right
scale for your data.
So try to avoid plotting
log-normally distributed
variables on a linear scale.
This can lead to
misleading interpretation,
especially when you introduce
lines and code uncertainty.
So in this example,
the uncertainty
appears to increase
above 1, which is unity.
But this is an artifact of
the choice of the scale.
Using a log scale
resolves this issue.
Another important
aspect related to this
is time and how
that is displayed.
So space measurements
proportional
to the time they were measured.
So what do we mean by that?
So measurements that are
displayed close together
are perceived to
be closer in time.
Not reflecting this
in your visualization
could introduce a visual bias.
So for example,
slopes or trajectories
may appear steeper or less
so than they typically are.
Law 3.
Make the Message Obvious.
A key aspect of this law is to
assume that the reader will--
not to assume that
the reader will
understand what message
is the information you're
trying to convey.
You have to really
work at it to get
them to understand
this information
or what you're trying
to convey to them.
A simple illustration of this
is to try and not to set text
at an angle.
Think of alternatives such
as transposing the graph.
So the left-hand plot,
we are essentially
asking the reader to tilt
their head to read the text.
Do we really want to
give readers neck strain?
A simple transposing
of the graph
allows us to resolve this
issue and also introduces
a more effective visualization.
Also, try to avoid
unnecessary color.
So avoid using color
to differentiate
between categories
of the same variable.
This can introduce
confusion in a similar way
to the previous pizza
example from YouGov.
Also, introducing unnecessary
color when it is not required
limits us to when we really
do need to use color later on.
For example, use color
when it adds value.
Use a bold, saturated,
or contrasting color
to emphasize important details.
So the left-hand plot,
our eyes are naturally
drawn to the top of the bar.
The right-hand plot, we
introduce a contrasting color.
Now our eyes are drawn to
the bottom of the bars.
This is an important
design choice
that allows us to
highlight key information
and can be used to really
highlight important messaging.
And here's an example of
using annotations and labels
to help with messages.
So use labels and
annotations to tell stories
about the data and models.
On the left-hand side we have
a typical dose response plot.
By adding annotations such as
Active Control and Target Dose
on the right-hand side, we
start to provide more contextual
information for the reader.
And then we can start to get
to the "why" of the plot.
So think back to the
flattening of the curve plot
where we add in the dotted line
to indicate the health care
system capacity.
So finally, here's
an example that we
created of a
visualization that tries
to follow all three principles.
The analysis is as a subgroup
comparison of a genetic marker.
The analysis is a repeated
measures model over time.
We use the title to indicate
a conclusion or recommendation
from the analysis.
So Genetic marker
positive is not
predictive of
treatment response.
We use annotations to indicate
the direction of the treatment
benefit.
And we also highlight
the main time point,
which is our primary analysis
at week 12 with a dotted circle.
Instead of legends,
we use annotations
to indicate each subgroup.
And we also use color
to differentiate
between subgroups.
So if you're interested
to learn more
about the three laws and some of
the principles I've introduced
today, I'd recommend that
you visit the website
below--
graphicprinciples.github.io.
We have a cheat sheet
there that summarizes
a lot of these principles.
And it's developed using R.
There are also other
great resources out there
that you can use.
For example, the book
by Jean-luc Doumont
really introduces
scientific communication.
And it's really an example of a
book that everyone should read.
If you're really interested
in data visualization,
I would recommend the other two
books, the Data Visualization
from Kieran Healy,
and also the book
by Claus Wilke, if you
wish to focus on not only
just the principles
of data visualization,
but also how to do this in R.
So effective data
visualization is
effective visual communication.
Effective visualizations
enable clear and impactful
communication, they evaluate
our influence with stakeholders,
and they facilitate
informed decision making.
To help design
effective visualizations
remember the three laws--
purpose, clarity, and message.
So typically now I
would do a handover that
would require either a strong
or a moderate handshake,
possibly a prolonged high five,
maybe just a normal high five,
or a prolonged fist bump.
But given the current
situation, I'll
just do a virtual fist
bump to Charlotta.
Charlotta.
CHARLOTTA FRUCHTENICHT:
Thank you, Mark.
So what you've seen
in this first section
is how important it is to
implement graphics principles
for effective visual
communication.
But the reason why we
are giving this webinar
is that you often don't see
that in typical data science
analyses.
And the reason for that
is that implementing
those visual
principles can be quite
tedious and
time-consuming and adding
quite a bit of extra
overhead on the coding side.
So especially early
on in project,
data scientists tend to skip
a lot of those principles
to just get on
with their project.
For example, if you
look on the right,
you can see that creating this
relatively simple dose response
curve, that's not even
adhering to all the principles
that Mark just described.
And you see that actually it
requires as much extra code
to style the diagram and
add annotations as it
does to plot the actual data.
So because of this extra
work, we often skip it.
But then downstream,
for example,
when communicating to
external stakeholders,
we have to keep
up with that work
and actually implement
new versions of the plots
and figures and tables
that we did early
on exploratory projects.
So we thought this is
something we'd probably
have to change if we want to
be more effective in the way we
communicate our results.
And if you go to the
next slide, Mark.
There is actually
an additional point.
And as Mark mentioned, there
are different stakeholders
or different audience to
your reporting outcomes.
So early on in a project
this might be just for you
and, like, yourself.
And you might remember all the
work you've done, all the data
manipulations, and you
might not need a lot
of additional annotations.
But usually you're working
in a team, at least
in clinical development.
And so you have
additional stakeholders
that might look at the
outputs that you create,
maybe figures of tables.
And you might actually
have those stakeholders
take those outputs and then
further use them to communicate
their insights in their teams.
So it's actually quite important
that whatever you create
in your analyses cannot
be taken out of context,
and that at any time it
is possible to reproduce
the output that you created--
tables and figures--
and also trace where
the data came from.
So on the right, you can
see a typical table shell
for baseline demographics
in the cohort.
And as you can
see clearly, we're
showing a table here because
Mark showed a lot of figures,
and we want to make sure that
you all are aware that outputs
can also be tables.
So if you have a
table you can see
that there is a lot of
metadata in addition
to the actual demographics
that are being annotated.
So for example, every table
and figure should have a title.
And it should name the
data source and the version
the data comes from.
So if that plot or that table
finds its way into a PowerPoint
presentation, it's easy to
trace back where it came from
and at what time point
the analysis was done.
We should always have also
as part of the rendered
object the information about the
abbreviations and table columns
that are being used, the
statistical tests that
were employed, as well as
some baseline information
or basic information about the
cohort, such as sample size.
Generally, also we would like to
have the reports that we create
to be harmonized across the
different visualizations--
plots and figures again--
so that, for example,
the same treatment
is always coded by the same
color in different plots.
So there is this second
layer in addition
to visual communication and
those graphics principles
that Mark just
introduced that we often
have to take into consideration
in our data science project.
And again, looking
at the metadata,
you can imagine that annotating
all of this information
can create quite a bit of
overhead on the coding side.
And these are often skipped
early on in projects.
So if you go to the next slide.
So we realize this is
something we have to change.
And as Mark said
in the beginning,
it's probably an issue
that not only data science
teams at Roche
and Novartis have,
but also a lot of other
people doing analytics work
across the industry and beyond.
So we thought we want
to implement something
like a tool box that
helps us integrate
graphical principles in our data
science and analytics projects.
We didn't want to do
that in a vacuum, though.
So we reached out to not
only other data scientists
in our own teams, but also
important stakeholders
like therapeutic area scientists
and clinical scientists
to better understand
what they would
like to see in typical
reports that we create
and what the crucial aspects are
that should never be missing.
And with that we came up
with a bunch of development
considerations that the tool
box we wanted to develop
should always adhere to.
And the first one is really
not creating extra work.
So it should integrate
seamlessly into our analytics
and reporting workflows.
And it should work well with
the tools we are already using.
So often the analyses
are done in R,
so it should play well
with the tidyverse.
The plotting should probably
be done using ggplot,
and then it should be rendered
in different output formats
like R Markdown using,
like, HTML output as well
as Word and LaTeX, or
interactively using Shiny.
The package or tool box should
be suitable for our special use
cases in clinical development,
but might also reach beyond.
And it should be
flexible enough so
that also expert users
find the tools useful
and like to use them to ease
some of the coding burden
and create, for example,
these additional metadata
objects around the visual output
they are already creating.
As Mark said, the
audience might actually
change for your outputs
as a project evolves.
And so the tool box should
allow us to easily adapt
to these different
target audiences
without having to repeat
the actual analysis.
And that could be, for
example, by exploring
different visualizations
of the same data set
and see which one helps us
adhere to those through three
laws that Mark introduced,
especially which
one helps us to convey the
message clearly and help
in decision making.
And as I said, the outputs
might make their way
through different stages
of stakeholders as well.
So it should be
possible to export them.
And there was something very--
being very critical
from our teammates
in the therapeutic area side
so that you can output them,
for example, so that they
can easily take the output
and present it in their
own presentations.
And so if you go
to the next slide.
This quickly led us to the
idea of developing an R package
because R is increasingly
popular and widely used
in our teams.
And it already
comes with a bunch
of really excellent
existing packages that
solve parts of the problems
that we just stated.
So there are
packages already that
allow very flexible
plotting opportunities.
For example, ggplot.
And we thought actually
building on those packages
and standing on the
shoulders of giants
here will make the
work less hard for us.
The other nice
part about using R
is that it is flexible towards
multiple analysis questions
and stages of the workflow.
And if we develop the package
that had different functions,
we could actually build
on the flexibility that
was so requested by R users.
We obviously can have the
documentation and testing.
And given that it's
open source, it's
really easy to collaborate
across companies and even
industries in the future
and contribute content.
If you go to the next slide.
So that's why we are now
presenting the visR package
in its current form, which
is actually is a still very
early experimental phase--
or you could actually call
it a prototype, maybe--
which we developed and would
like to hear feedback of you
all later on, as well.
We thought, too, there are a
few architecture considerations
we put in in order to
implement those considerations
and requirements that we got
in our earlier stakeholder
interviews.
So the first one was really
about this seamless integration
into the tidyverse in
our analysis workflow.
So we thought whatever
we do, it should interact
with key player and
the modeling packages,
and plotting should
be built on ggplot.
We also want to keep
full transparency
on data modifications, first
of all, for the reproducible
reporting aspect, but also for
being able to scale projects
across different stages.
And that led us to
this decoupled design
that you can see on the
right where we actually
take our input data--
let's say, for example,
one row per sample,
one row per patient data set.
And then we have
dedicated functions
that take care of the data
wrangling and the modeling
before another set
of functions takes
care of the visualization.
And that visualization
ideally adheres
to the graphical principles
that Mark just described before.
And then last but not least,
we have a separate set
of functions, again,
that takes care
of the styling of the outputs.
So there shouldn't be any hard
coded theming, for example,
in the plotting function.
But that is then taken care
of and allows us, for example,
to adapt the visualization
to corporate designs.
But it also allows us to
adapt the visualization
to be consistent
across a report where,
for example, the treatments are
always colored in the same way
across.
We mentioned before as well that
in addition to being flexible,
though, the coding
of and adhering
to those graphical principles
shouldn't add a lot of overhead
to the coding work you're doing
as a data scientist anyways.
So we thought it
would be great to have
in addition to those
individual decoupled functions
the wrapper functions
that allow you
to explore different
visualizations
for typical analysis questions.
So one, to pick a question
in clinical development
when working with a patient
cohort in the beginning
is, for example, to see how many
of those patients in the data
set adhere to a set of inclusion
and exclusion criteria.
And you might want to
show the cohort attrition.
And there are different
ways of doing that,
and Diego will talk
about it a bit later.
But having a wrapper
function that
allows you to explore these
different visualizations
can then help you
quickly find out
which visualization
might be the best
one to convey your
message clearly
to the target audience
you're currently
designing your report for.
If you go to the next slide.
So this was all very
theoretical so far.
And it's still
going to stay a bit
theoretical for
the next two slides
before I hand over to Diego.
But what I want to
show here is really
how this would look
if you implemented it
for a typical question,
another typical question,
around time-to-event analysis.
And so by having
decoupled functions,
if we had our initial input
data model for patient data
that has, for example,
intervention like treatment,
and then the time of
followup or time to event,
and the status at
the end, then we
wouldn't go directly from this
input data model to the plot.
But we would go through
three individual steps.
The first one is really
taking this input data
and have an estimator
function that
computes the estimate, in
this case, the survival model.
And after cleaning
that with broom,
we get a data
table, or a tibble,
as an interim data
model, which we can then
build our visualizations on.
And in this case,
for example, it
would contain the
time, the stratum,
as well as the estimates
at different time points,
and the confidence intervals.
And these can then
be easily passed on
to ggplot, for example,
for visualization.
As I said before, we didn't
want to reinvent the wheel
where this wasn't necessary.
So we are building a
lot of those functions
on existing packages of
the tidyverse and beyond,
such as broom, or in
this case, also Survival.
The idea is by having this
multi-tier approach that you
can define a lot of
custom features that
might be required, such
as custom time windows
or adding hypothesis tests.
And so after you have
this interim data model,
you'd have the visualization
function, and then
the styling in
the end that helps
you allow to adhere to
those graphical principles
that we spoke a
bit about before.
And so if you go
to the next slide.
Mark.
Mark, can you go
to the next slide?
Or is it stuck just when we--
OK.
Thank you.
So these were a lot of
the design considerations
that are definitely
not set in stone.
So if people have ideas
and thoughts about it,
we would love to hear them.
But Diego will show you
now in the next few slides
how we implemented the prototype
and what those outputs look
like for now.
And with that I would like
to hand over to you, Diego.
DIEGO SALDANA:
Thanks, Charlotta.
Yeah.
So now that Charlotta
has introduced
the main architecture
considerations
and the main concepts that
we used to design a package,
let's look at this
in the context
of a practical application.
So let's look at this in
the context of a time--
your typical time-to-event
analysis workflow.
And so when we're carrying
out these types of analyses,
there's a number of
steps that will be there
virtually every time we
carry out these analyses.
And all of which require
some level of communicating
results or communicating
interim results, and which
can be communicated in different
ways depending on the audience
and depending on
the circumstances as
mentioned also by Mark before.
And so for example, you
might start with something
like building your
analysis cohorts.
So you might want to
understand how many patients
are kept after applying certain
inclusion/exclusion criteria.
And you might want to show
that by either showing
a table or a flow chart.
Then once you have
your analysis cohort,
you might want to understand
their baseline characteristics
of the population
that you're analyzing.
And so you might do that
using some kind of Table One,
which is a very popular table
that's used in virtually--
well, in virtually
every paper out there
on these types of studies.
And then you might be
interested in doing
some kind of survival analysis.
And for that you
might plot something
like a Kaplan-Meier
plot, or you might
want to show some tables
showing the median survival.
So there are different
things that you
might want to show
as interim results
and that all require a certain
level of code and programming
and effort and time.
And so we as data
scientists spend
a lot of time redoing these
a lot of very often, right.
So can we go to
next slide, please?
So now let's look
at these one by one.
So the first one was
building an analysis cohort.
Right.
And so first, the
philosophy that we
have tried to
follow with visR was
that we wanted to, as
Charlotta mentioned,
not create more work.
But we also wanted
this to implement sort
of out-of-the-box best practices
and also reuse the knowledge
that we have acquired through
our own experience and through
interviews that we
have carried out.
And so the way this
works, as you can see,
you can create a list of
filters as well as descriptions.
So it takes very little code
to create your cohort attrition
using this visR.
And then really creating a table
that shows the attrition just
takes basically five lines
of code using this function
called vr_render_table.
And then you can output this
nicely formatted table that
shows you the relevant
information, including
the criteria that's
being applied,
what's the condition,
how many patients
are being kept and excluded, as
well as percentages for these.
And of course, it
comes with nice--
I mean, it will show nicely
formatted titles as well as
metadata that might be
relevant, such as data sources.
And so you don't have to
spend a lot of time thinking
of what should I show to the--
what should I show
in this plot in order
to follow best practices.
Again, little code, very
little code, and nicely
formatted outputs follows best
practices and reuses knowledge.
Can we go to the next slide?
So then you might
also want to show
this in the form of
a flowchart, which
is a very typical visualization
of the attrition diagram.
And so, again, this
takes very little code.
You can create a vector
of complement descriptions
as well as reduce the outputs
from the previous chunk
of code.
And using this
vr_attrition function,
you can plot this nicely
formatted attrition diagram,
which shows at each
step how many patients
have been kept and excluded.
And this is a very
popular, again,
figure that shows up in many
real world data analyses
papers.
And I should highlight
that this type of package
can help us better comply
with reporting guidelines
like CONSORT and STROBE.
Can we go to the
next slide, please.
So once we have selected
our baseline population
and our analyses
cohort, we might
be interested in showing
and understanding
the baseline characteristics.
And so this is typically done
using the very popular Table
One.
We looked at a number of
implementations of it,
and we couldn't find one
that really satisfied all
the requirements that we had.
So we have created our own.
The nice thing about it is
that it's very flexible.
So it comes already with a very
good inbuilt summary functions
that will help you summarize
your categorical as well
as numerical variables
out of the box.
But it also lets you input
your own custom built
summary functions if
they don't satisfy
your specific requirement.
It also outputs the tables
in different formats,
including kable, RStudio/gt,
as well as DT html tables.
And importantly, it also lets
you download the Table One
at Excel or CSV, which was
one of the requests that
came the most often
when we interviewed
our internal scientists.
And again, it takes
very little code.
It's about four lines
of code, and again,
follows best practices
and reuses the knowledge
that we have acquired.
Can we go to next slide.
So finally, we might be
interested-- or actually, next.
We might be interested
in-- no, no.
Sorry.
It's the same.
Yeah.
We might be interested in
doing a survival analysis.
So this is typically done using
a Kaplan-Meier curve together
with a risk table.
And usually there's a
number of metadata elements
that are important here.
And so I should
highlight that we
have based our design of our
Kaplan-Meier visualization
on the outcome and the
findings of a paper
by Morris and collaborators
that was conducted
among a large number
of researchers
about what a good Kaplan-Meier
plot should look like.
And so our Kaplan-Meier plot
shows relevant information out
of the box, including things
like number of patients,
nicely formatted axis labels
including units where needed,
as well as a data source
from which the plot was made.
It also shows the risk table
in a format including things
like numbers, number of patients
at risk, number of events,
and number of censoring events
as well grouped by stratum
at regular time points.
And this format actually
follows the recommendations
by Morris and collaborators.
So again, this is reusing
knowledge and best s
Can we go to next slide?
So how do we do this?
Using visR, it's very simple.
We have two options.
One is either we plot the
Kaplan-Meier curve alone
using the first chunk here and
then the risk table alone using
the second chunk
here in the middle.
And both of these show
our design philosophy
of separating the
estimation from the plotting
and the styling.
But then we also have
the option of plotting
all of this in one go
and one function call.
And it's the chunk
in the bottom here.
So this one is just
one function call,
and then gives you
that nice plot.
Again, very little code, reuses
best practices and knowledge.
Can we go to next slide?
So finally, we have
also implemented
a set of convenient
estimation functions,
including median
survival times by stratum
as well as multiple
methods for testing
equality between strata.
And again, you can
do this very easily
with only a few lines of code.
And it shows you very
nicely formatted tables
that follow best practices.
Can we go to next slide?
So now going into
our package roadmap,
I would like to highlight that
this is still a prototype.
So we are basically
reaching now the stage
where we have our prototype
that's reaching the state
where it's ready.
And now we are
reaching the stage
where we want to launch this
initiative out there and find
and identify
collaborators to kickstart
the next step of our projects.
Can we go to next slide, please?
And so with that
I'd like to announce
that we're looking for
contributors to join the visR
team.
So again, visR is still in
its experimental stages.
We welcome feedback and
ideas for features using
GitHub issues, for example.
So actually there are two ways
in which you can contribute.
The first one is what we
call the open source way.
And so this is the
informal collaboration,
where you might pick up an issue
and work on it proactively.
The second way it might be
the more formal way where
you reach out to us, and then
we can see together if it makes
sense for you to try
to join our core team.
And so what kind
of contributions
are we looking for?
So we're open to
hearing your ideas
in turn and ask for design
choices, project governance,
hands-on engineering,
as well as how
to maintain an
actively used package.
And if you want to reach
out, please reach out
to Mark Baille and James Black,
whose emails are listed here.
Can we go to the next slide?
Finally, I'd like to acknowledge
that many other people have
been involved in the
development of this package.
So we would like to thank them.
And also, we have made heavy use
of open source packages, which
are listed here, without
which this prototype would not
have been possible to develop.
And with that, I'd like
to hand over to Marc.
MARC VANDEMEULEBROECKE: Yeah.
So thanks, Diego.
And thanks, Mark and Charlotta.
That's the end of
the presentation.
And I guess we can
start the Q&amp;A session.
Let me start with one of
the questions that came in
during the presentations.
Someone has asked, are you
going to open collaborations
with federal agencies?
And we are working with
various other groups.
But more specifically,
maybe Mark,
do you want to
take this question?
MARK BAILLE: Yeah.
Thanks, Marc.
We would be open to
collaborating with anyone.
This is part of a wider
set of collaborations.
So for example, the PSI--
the Pharmaceutical
Statistics Initiative--
has sort of started a
special interest group
on data visualization
where a number of us
are currently joint members of.
And also, there's the
Stratus Collaboration,
which is related
to this, which is
looking at methodology as a
whole for observational data.
But yes, we would be
open to collaborations
from any avenues.
Thank you, Mark.
Another question
that came in earlier
was, when will this
package be on [? Crayon? ?]
DIEGO SALDANA: Yeah.
Yeah.
So as I said currently,
it's in prototype stages.
I think we would still
have to probably go further
into development in order
to put it into [? Crayon. ?]
But definitely we have
it in our radar to do.
MARC VANDEMEULEBROECKE:
[INAUDIBLE] Thank you.
Another question
was, what do you
mean by "join the core team"?
Charlotta.
CHARLOTTA FRUCHTENICHT:
Thank you, Marc.
"Join the core team" I guess
means that at the moment
we are this relatively
small group of people
who have regular meetings
around aspects like the package
architecture, for example.
And while you might
not want to commit
to having those alignment
meetings and other aspects,
I guess if you
joined the core team,
this would be part of, like,
driving the general direction
of the package, making design
choices, and things like that.
Whereas if you just
picked an issue on GitHub
and contributed to it, that
would be the less involvement
in the overall direction.
MARC VANDEMEULEBROECKE:
Thank you, Charlotta.
So there's two questions,
which are relatively similar.
One was, is this focusing
on clinical data only?
And another
question, do you have
a sub team focused on
reporting for real world data?
So I guess overall,
the question is, what's
the focus of this effort?
Mark, do you want
to take that one?
MARK BAILLE: I would
say the general focus
at the moment is
exploratory analysis
of clinical and medical data.
Probably Diego and Charlotta
could back to me up here.
But they work primarily
on real world data.
So it is a mixture of
clinical and real world data.
MARC VANDEMEULEBROECKE:
Thank you, Mark.
A quick one was, can
you share the link again
to those graphical principles?
I will take this one.
You can see it on
this last slide.
And here's another one.
Do you have any recommendations
for developing visualizations
for different kinds of users--
users with different fluency
in data, for example?
Diego, what are your
thoughts on this one?
DIEGO SALDANA: Yeah.
I think in general, as Mark
mentioned before, it's really
about knowing your audience.
So I really couldn't
give you, like, one rule
of thumb for everything.
But we definitely need,
I think, just in--
as for like how we are handling
that with the package, that's
really part of why
we have decided
to sort of separate the
idea of doing estimates
and visualizations and having
multiple ways of presenting
a message, because yeah,
as Mark said, really
you should know your audience.
And so that also translates
into being able to show things
in different-- or being
able to communicate
your results in different ways.
And so that flexibility
is something
that we want to embed
in our project as well.
MARC VANDEMEULEBROECKE:
Thank you, Diego.
I'll move on to a question
regarding compatibility.
Two people have asked
about intentions
to combine this with LaTeX or
somehow create a link to LaTeX.
And on the other hand, whether
we are planning to create
some templates for
reporting with R Markdown.
So both of the questions
maybe can go to Mark.
MARK BAILLE: Yeah.
At the moment I guess the
Table One is an example where
the engine can change,
but the underlying data
or the reporting of the
data should not change.
So I do believe that
LaTeX is an option,
but hasn't been implemented.
I possibly need to hand it
over to Charlotta to confirm.
But we would be looking
at different engines,
too, for reporting.
CHARLOTTA FRUCHTENICHT: Yeah.
Just to add to that,
actually, and I
saw there was another question
on the chat about gt summary.
So the reason why we build
our own table rendering
was to support different
engines, namely kable, GT
and DT.
And that is specifically because
some of these already come
with LaTeX support.
And that is implemented
already, at least
in the rudimentary form.
Regarding templates, I
think that's a great idea.
We haven't really-- we haven't
really reached that stage yet.
But we try to
create the functions
at the moment in the
flexible way that
allows easy integration in
different markdown output
formats, as well as Shiny.
MARC VANDEMEULEBROECKE: Thank
you, Mark and Charlotta.
Here's a question.
Is it plans to have
only survival analysis
or other epidemiological
model or analysis?
I think the answer
is clearly yes,
we want to expand to many
different types of analysis.
Common ones and gradually
perhaps a little less
common ones as well.
One question I think is
important here just coming in.
What level of
proficiency are you
looking for in contributors?
Maybe Charlotta, do you
want to answer this one?
CHARLOTTA FRUCHTENICHT: Sure.
I guess we are open for
all levels of proficiency.
So as we said, this package
is at a really early stage.
So we'd love to hear and
see people contribute
who have a lot of experience
in developing R packages,
from which we could
probably learn quite a bit,
being more on the data
sides and domain expert side
at the moment.
But then also people who
come in who would be, like,
target users or who want
to write documentation
or vignettes are very welcome.
So all levels of proficiency
are welcome to join the team.
MARC VANDEMEULEBROECKE:
Thank you very much.
And maybe a last
question, because we only
have one minute left.
Someone has asked
about the possibility
to incorporate
corporate branding color
schemes and the like on top of
the good graphical principles.
The answer is clearly yes.
That's the way the
package is designed.
It should be possible
to plug your personal,
or your company's
corporate branding,
at the very last step on
top of the visualizations.
[MUSICAL STRUM]